30 i call this meeting of the public
works and highways committee
to order and as required
i will read the following script
as chair of the house public works and
highways committee i find that due to
the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-05
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a full committee work session on
house bill 25
with an executive session to follow
please note that there is no physical
location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
this notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91-8 anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting
should call 271-3600
leg.state.nh.u.s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
in the meeting assisting us
brad greenland committee researcher and
christopher shea of the lba
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let us start the meeting by taking the
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law mr clerk
please call the roll thank you mr chair
chairman graham i am my house
in bedford and you may hear the dog but
that's the only
thing here representative mcconkey
uh president in my office with my
clerk is here his wife is somewhere
sleeping downstairs
representative sumero i am present i am
here
alone in my room representative phil
dolphy
ah i am here in hillsborough my wife's
representative newton
representative blasic here i am all
alone my family is upstairs
representative gagne
representative thompson
representative dan de castillo
representative clutier uh present alone
in the bedroom of my claremont home
representative edgar president
uh kathy's in the house someplace around
representative ebal home alone in new
london
home alone in nashua representative
abbott
representative faulkner i am a home in
swansea my wife is in the other room
representative newman yes i'm at home
in nashua my husband is in the house
that's it representative grassy
i'm home in rochester my wife is in the
house as well
representative peterson
president at home in nashua alone
representative query present
uh at home in manchester with my dog
representative bunker presents at home
in exeter my wife may pass through from
thank you mr chair the attendance is
complete
i didn't representative thompson thank
you
hello can anybody hear me yes we can
okay
this is uh representative joining the
meeting
thank you hello
who vandy castille is present
i'll go over it one more time then
representative newton
are you here
all right mr chair of the attendance has
you're muted mr uh rep uh mr chairman
yeah i make that mistake just like
everybody else
um i open this uh
portion of the meeting which is the work
session
lately um
who is on everybody mute please thank
you
all um we sent out
um the updated compare report based on
what we had agreed to
um you will find
that mr shea had also put the footnotes
on the compare reports so we knew what
was going to
be used um i went through it i did not
see any changes
and then also you should have received
an amendment to house bill 25a um
number zero nine eight one
h uh dated march 23rd
that is the amendment that we will be
approving
hopefully in a few minutes um
but i would open the floor to any
discussion that anybody has about either
the compare report
or more importantly the amendment to
raise your hand if you want to
representative abbott yes mr chairman
i'd just like to move that the amendment
uh
be ought to pass as amended well
i i i understand the amendment that that
that the motion you are making
is to approve amendment 2021-091-h
representative mills seconds the
motion i would ask that if you are
making or seconding
motions that you unmute and say it out
loud
so that the public can see it because
they can't always see you
raising a hand or signaling to be in
some other fashion
okay it's been moved and seconded that
we approve
uh the committee approve amendment
2021-3
h to house bill 25a
seeing no hands raised the clerk will
call the roll
thank you mr chair representative
mcconkey
aye the clerk votes yes
representative sumero i vote
yes thank you representative
philadelphia
yes thank you sir representative newton
representative newton representative
blasic
representative gagne
yes thank you sir
representative kolansky representative
thompson
yes thank you
representative van der casteel
representative edgar all right
representative ebel yes
representative jack yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman yes
representative grassy yes
representative query yes
she was thumbs up david she has no audio
yeah okay it's fixed now yes
thank you very much because i could not
see that
uh i'll do once more representative
kolansky
representative newton
thank you sir the amendment passes 19
to zero thank you mr clerk
uh before i ask for a motion on
the bill overall i would just like to
say
it is important that we we do this
and i appreciate everybody's hard work
on it
and i know that there are things in this
bill as i said to say
that each of us would either change add
delete
position where we are by by working
together and
i hope that now for whoever makes the
motion
um do not worry that you will have to
write the excuse me committee report
because i am uh writing it and i will
submit it to the calendar
uh so i think
that has been the past practice going
back at least four by eddie when i
looked at the old
um blurbs for the for hb 25
is always under the chairman's name so i
will do that
representative philadelphia mr chair
yeah
interrupt please i would just like to
say
that in the past two years i was on this
committee right
those of you who might be new to the
committee
i have found the democratic leadership
to be fair
and just as as much as the
republican leadership and even i'm not
usually not having the bill of economy
but it was 23 pages
so my printer wouldn't handle that
my dead all i want to say
represent mr chairman
i'm sorry i'm i'm sorry i wanted to just
go on record as correcting that vote
uh when i went back to uh representative
andy castillo i
i've logged it out of order in error
so the actual vote on that committee
amendment was 20
to zero yep
thank you um representative clutier
okay thank you mr chairman i just want
to say uh i think this is a good
budget it's not everything that i
necessarily like every little thing but
i think it's a budget we all came
together on with some
discussion give and take compromise and
i think it's a great budget to send to
the floor
so i i think i want to say hats off to
you mr chair and everybody else in the
committee i think
worked hard and tried to in the end came
together to compromise to send a good
budget
to the floor for the benefit of our
entire state thank you
and i recognize uh representative
mcconkey for
you just muted yourself mark all right
thank you how's that that's a little
better
um mr chairman i would i would like to
uh move
passage of house bill 25
uh to pass as amended is what i heard as
as
as amended mr chairman okay the motion
by representative mcconkey that house
bill 25
be found ought to pass as amended
is there a second
[Music]
multiple seconds representative faulkner
uh
was first up uh so it's been moved and
seconded
that uh house bill 25a
be ought to pass as amended there any
discussion
thank you mr chair representative
mcconkey
aye the clerk votes yes
representative sumero
i vote yes thank you representative
dolphy yes
representative newton representative
blasic
representative gagne yes
thank you sir representative kolansky
yes thank you sir representative van di
castille
i vote yes thank you
representative clutier uh yes
thank you representative edgar hi
thank you representative ebel yes
thank you representative jack yes
thank you representative abbott yes
thank you representative faulkner yes
thank you sir representative newman yes
thank you representative grassy yes
chairman graham yes
mr chair of the vote on hb 25 a auto
pass is amended is
20 to zero yay thank you very much
i i this is a joke any objection to
consent calendar
uh unfortunately we cannot do that
because it is a budget bill
um we have tried it in the past and
never worked
so we're not even gonna try try
but as i said earlier to before we
started the official meeting to a couple
of the members who are on
um i have asked the speaker to move this
to the start of the session on uh
april 7th um hopefully we can do that to
be the first bill up
maybe set a cordial tone in the house
before we start our
um debates on house bill one and two
um and just be able to do that
um as i
look at the calendar i had
scheduled a meeting and it will be in
the calendar
for house bill 25 executive session
on monday the 29th if necessary
obviously it is not necessary but there
were some
concerns on my part you know if the
public couldn't have access then
um we would had to reschedule and
if we had hit a snag with something
wrong with the amendment
we would have had to reschedule either
late keep it open and
come back in a few hours on this so you
can disregard that
when you get the notice that there's a
um a meeting of
uh public works and highways next monday
we will not be meeting at all next week
um
and i do not intend to meet until
sometime
in april we currently have four bill
about three bills
and i've just been informed that a
fourth one dealing with the highway plan
will be coming to us it was
inadvertently sent to transportation
i none of them are
early bills and we can work them all at
the same time
the bills if you're interested in what
they are
are listed under public works committee
on the
with that i want to thank everybody
um and
um i do as i said at the very beginning
of this session
um i like to start things on time i hope
that the members are not here
are not hoping to sign in later and
see us because we're not going to be
here
so i thank you all
it's been a challenge i think for all of
us to try to do this
via either hybrid or totally remote
usually it's easier to talk across that
u-shaped table in
room 201 about some of these issues
whereas we've had to do it
uh either on paper or or talking across
the zoom platform it has been
rewarding but we also haven't got to
know each other
and there are a lot of new members on
the committee that i've met
at the last house session and that's
been about it other than
on here so um hopefully
by may we'll be back doing things a
little more normally
but we shall see what what happens
any thing else any questions anybody has
of me mr chairman
uh yes president thompson
i'd just like to say that of all the
political organizations and boards that
i'm now involved in
this is the most collegial and
non-partisan group of people
i've yet to meet in state government
local government or anywhere else
and i appreciate it as a freshman member
um
the help that's been given to me in the
time that's been taken to explain things
so
i i want everyone to know i appreciate
that
and that was the goal and it's the goal
of every returning member on this
committee
as i said at our orientation we work
collegially
we don't always get what we want but
um we try to work it out and see where
we are
so i appreciate those comments dennis it
it means a lot
to me personally that we are doing that
all right i would ask one thing
if anybody knows of any member of either
party
who is planning to speak against house
bill 25
on the floor if they could let me know
um i don't you know we'll know that
morning but
sometimes to arrange for a debate if we
have to have a debate
i will be defending the the committee's
recommendation but if there's somebody
who is going to speak against it if
somebody could just let me know i'm not
going to try to talk them out and not
doing it that's their right to
dispute what a community does but it
helps
structure debates and time
and it does really help the speaker and
the clerk to
um figure out how long we're going to
have to be there but uh wednesday
thursday and friday of that week
so i that's just a request that i make
to all of you if you hear anything
just let me know and if they are going
to speak they need to let the clerk know
as well
with that any other comments i'm
mr chairman if i could just interject
[Music]
i would like to thank you um as chairman
and vice chairman mcconkie
and the clerk mr mills
and also the raps
and zoom commander
smart jack and the former speaker
john cloudier if
if this could be a model for
state government or national government
it would be certainly welcome as far as
i'm concerned
is seeing what can be accomplished with
cooperation in what really is
bipartisanship
thank you well let's not all of us get
too carried away we still have
bills later in this year and bill's next
year
uh but we shall see but we work towards
that you know that
uh mike abbott uh representative mills
there we go thank you mr chair i wanted
to
ask our representative clutier a
question in
because as far as i can remember he's
been on this committee the longest
in my memory the last five terms this is
the at least the fifth time that house
bill 25 has gone to the floor
on a unanimous vote i think
and it stands to show how well run this
committee is
and how well we get cohesive and
standing behind all this so
mr cloudy can you can you add anything
to that uh representative yeah
yeah i think it's unanimous again i mean
yeah five well of course i've been here
i i maybe in my early term there might
have been one or two
opposing the capital budget but usually
we send it to the floor
and uh usually there's not a lot of
debate i mean we might have a roll call
vote like we did last turn uh
term when i was chair but there are only
a few votes in opposition it passed
overwhelming and i just basically took
questions
so hopefully it's going to be that way
this uh
term as well there'll be no debate on
the floor and we can pass it on a voice
vote
or at least a division or roll call with
little or no debate
but again yeah we're one of the better
committees as far as we don't
especially on things like the capital
budget and 10-year plan we don't usually
have a lot of opposition i
from what i i experience and a lot
maybe in the earlier days there were a
few controversies more on other bills i
think usually the capital budget
and 10-year plan are something we can
you know unite on even if we don't
totally get our way on everything
thank you seeing
no other hands raised um
again thank you all um
i will let you um know
when i schedule these bills my intention
is to try to do as many of them
in one day as possible so that we're not
trying to
take up an hour here an hour there on
zoom time
because once all the senate bills come
over we're once again
into the okay who's got the license for
the zoom
on what days um so if we can do it
a couple of them are naming bills and so
we'll go
representative philadelphia you raised
your hand again
yes i just want to thank
the members of the committee
that send emails and phone calls and
cards
when i was ill thank you very much
and a special thanks to representative
gagne and representative grassy for
joining us
today i appreciate it
it's always a pleasure to have somebody
else come in and see that we
how we do our work so thank you
um unless the vice chair or the clerk
has any administrative
things
i think you're i think your cuckoo said
it all mr chair all right
time to leave is what it's saying i
guess
um that is the danger of trying to do
things at home
um at least the dog hasn't been barking
you're right
um i thank you all again um
and i look forward to uh seeing you all
on the 7th 8th and 9th of april
um so thank you thank you
this everybody session of house bill 25a